où
cher journal aujourd'hui j'ai eu rendez
vous avec ma psy et je n'avais pas très
envie de parler de moi pour une fois ce
qui est plutôt rare je trouvais qu'elle
avait l'air triste
s'il ya bien un endroit où l'on peut
parler de ce qui ne va pas c'est dans un
cabinet de psy alors il me semble
qu'elle est au bon endroit
je vais envie de le proposer une séance
sur elle de savoir comment elle allait
c'est étrange donnera un savoir sur
quelqu'un qui sait tout de moi enfin
elle ne sait pas que j'écris sur elle
par exemple celle sais pas à moins
qu'elle ne tombe un jour sur toi cher
journal tunisien serait bien mais ils
vont essayer pâle pour que j'avais envie
qu'on boive un verre et qu'elle me parle
et qu'elle se raconter qu'elle me paye
aussi oui au pressage ya du nouveau avec
ce garçon là que vous aimez bien qui
vous amuse à m
petite copine qui postent m
nous
je lui ai dit qu'elle avait l'air triste
mais elle a cru que je parlais de la
copine du garçon que j'aime bien qu'il
n'ose pas quitté elle m'a dit que
c'était sûrement à cause de moi qu'elle
devait se douter de quelque chose mais
j'ai perdu le fil j'ai pas très bien
compris de qui on parle et chocolat j'en
ai conclu que ma psy était triste à
cause de moi et qu'elle se doutait de
quelque chose mais de quoi ça que
j'écris sur ans est ce qu'elle est tombé
sur toi charge de mal pourtant j'ai rien
dit de mal
enfin je crois pas je me demande si je
devrais voir un psy pour parler de ma
psy j'ai peur que salle avec ce nom on
verra une prochaine fois pour moi c'est
pas très grave en fait
tenez je les payais pour tenté de la
réconforter
mais je crois que ce sont les 50 euros
les plus tristes qu'elle n'ait jamais
gagné au revoir j'espère que ça va aller
courageux moi en tout cas ça va enfin
[Rires]
[Musique]